all right we are back with another video
guys I'm sorry Ivan uploaded in a week
but we are now back and I think I'll
have a normal upload scheduled until the
end of the year I have a couple things
to say before we kick off this video the
first thing is we are almost at five
thousand sub and my goal by the end of
the year was to actually hit 5k but I
think we'll hit it after this video
because we're gonna be giving away not 5
guys we're gonna be giving away 8 bonds
shout out to 55 mini this guy contacted
me in-game guys left a comment on my
channel and wanted to add to the
giveaway for 5,000 and he gave us 3
bonds which was really really nice of
him big shout out to this guy honestly
the true MVP and yeah if you ever want
to add to the giveaway just contact me
through the YouTube comments and I'll be
sure to add you anyways now that we have
that out of the way and you guys know
there's giveaway going on all you need
to do to enter is leave your orison in
the comments and sub to the channel not
too hard to do takes about 5 seconds
there's gonna be 8 bonds you have a nice
chance of winning good luck to everyone
who enters now let's talk about today's
video we're gonna be starting with 200
ml and see how much money we can make
flipping for 1 hour on the grand
exchange keep in mind I'm not the best
flipper out there which is why I think
it's gonna be an interesting video to
watch I've done it once in the past we
flipped with a hundred mil before in the
last video I made in one hour and we
didn't break the 1 mil mark so hopefully
today we can do that and I'm very
confident that we can guys because not
only are we gonna be using double the
amount we used last time we're gonna be
using a secret weapon yes GE tracker now
one of the staff at GE tracker a website
that basically revolves around to giving
you information about the grand exchange
contacted me and he asked me if I'd like
to partner up with them and after
looking into the website which is just
beautiful in my opinion it's just the
way it's developed it's just amazing I
could not resist doing it because it
perfectly follows through with like a
one-hour challenge video I could have
made and it does support the channel
guys so if you want to check out the
website the referral link will be in the
description I'm gonna show you what it's
all about right now now when you first
come to the website this is what you're
gonna see as you can see there's a bunch
of tabs here this is the home page all
you have to do is start using this
website is register but we already have
an account so we're just gonna log into
that real quick once you're logged in
you will be brought to this beautiful
home page login it so you can see they
have a discord in the YouTube but yeah
we are logged in to our account right
now as you can see s challenge and let
they've done
is they've given me the Premium
Membership so I have all the features to
the website and boy there are a lot of
features on this website as you can see
on the left here we've got the flip
finder the moneymaker the profit tracker
flipping leaderboards for the most
profit flips there is a bunch here now
obviously when you sign up you won't
have the premium benefits now to get
premium you have to pay two pounds a
month I mean for the time they put in to
make this website I think it is
definitely a good deal look no further
there is a free version and a 2-day
premium trial if you want to try all the
features I'm gonna talk about more them
towards the end of the video let's get
into the one hour of flipping with 200
mil we're just gonna head right into the
grand exchange screen and right before I
start now what I'm gonna be using here
is the highest margins tab because we
want to make the most money per hour now
obviously I'm not gonna be flipping a 38
PO because they don't have that amount
of cash but it shows you a lot of neat
things like the selling quantity per
hour to see if it's actually worth
flipping those items so we're going to
try to pick one with a decent selling
quantities you can see the Armadale
chestplate is sold and bought around 20
times per hour so we're gonna start with
that item so now that we're all ready
what we're gonna do here is start the
timer we're gonna put in our offers for
the first item the our middle chest
plate so it was buying it around thirty
three point four we're gonna put it in
for thirty three point four five and
we're just gonna try to buy four of
these for now it's gonna take a huge
chunk of our money out but that's okay
now we're just gonna look for the second
item here gilded plate legs look very
nice it is not too expensive let's pop
those right in and gild it plate legs
buying for around three mil and we're
gonna put an offer for about four those
as you can see we already bought an
armadillo chest plate which is really
nice so we're just gonna pop that back
in around thirty three point five four
so if we can do this we've just made a
nice profit off of that flip right there
sir Pelham looks really promising right
now one of the raids items the dragon
hunter crossbow seems to actually be
traded a lot and it is a 74th kay margin
21.1 mil and 55 k we're gonna try our
luck with some barrows the back plate
skirt has a almost 10k margin and I were
just gonna wait for some stuff to sell
and buy here alright there it is we
bought a dragon hunter crossbow and sold
a serpentine helm as you guys can see on
the serpentine helm flip we sold it for
two point five eight
and we bought it for 2.51 a which is a
10k flip dragon hunter crossbows what
I'm excited for it because the margin is
nuts she's gonna put it for twenty four
point two millimeter Merv Eric play
skirts and a sir poem just gonna put the
sir poem in again we sold it for two
five to eight K I'm just gonna pop it in
this should go really quick a lot of
people buy these we have a full GE so
we're just gonna wait might take out the
gilded plate legs cuz none of them have
bought yet but we just have to be
patient
alright all the army old chest plates
actually just came in I'm not gonna
undercut too hard I'm just gonna put the
margin for around three thirty five
forty K to get a little bit of cash back
I'm just gonna abort the gilded plate
legs and these sir poems and I'm gonna
try to flip the arm dual crossbow
alright so the dragon hunter crossbow
just sold as you guys can see we got
like a 45 K margin there which is really
nice we put in the our middle crossbow
offer because it had the nice margins
and we just bundled the varrock plate
skirts together now I'm not actually
sure what these are flipping for at the
moment so we're just gonna search it up
on the website and check the graphs
it's buying for thirty three point four
selling for thirty three point five six
so I'm just gonna be patient with these
and let them sell off and the our middle
crossbow just bought again which is
really nice we're gonna pop that in for
the same price as the other one they
should solve that price in the next like
five or ten minutes yeah one instantly
just sold as I said that this is why I
love this website you don't have to
check your margins buying and selling
items because this website updates it
like every because this website updates
the price and it's very accurate so
everything I'm flipping is like above a
50k margin and boom 100k made just like
that off those armies of crossbows
honestly while we solve the limit let's
just buy another one like I feel like
I'm honestly just cheating using this
website look at this stuff's just
selling left and right and buying
telling me all these prices it's making
my life so easy if you're a new flipper
I would really recommend using all right
sir demand godsword has a 53k margin
there it is
we just bought and sold another our
middle crossbow just like that look at
this 42 K margins we just keep doing
this every time we're gonna keep doing
this until we run out of the limit for
these because this is just this is just
free money at this point we're gonna put
it in for forty six point one three and
nine mil here okay so I can flip them
four more times which is gonna be like
another 200k
you guys are actually new to flipping
and you don't know which items to flip a
have a suggested items tab under the
flipped finder and you've got all these
juicy items but we're trying to make the
most profit per hour that's why we're on
the highest margins page there we go
both tormented bracelets finally bought
gonna abort this one chuck them in for a
little lower just gonna recheck the
margins yeah as you guys can see it
updates like every 20 minutes see I was
trying to sell them higher than this
price right here twelve point one seven
seven so now I know I have to put it in
for 12 1 7 5k just gonna put it in for
that all right we got another SGS flip
off I actually put another offer in the
varrock plate skirts finally all bought
and another on the bill crossbow flip
we're just gonna keep doing these as
long as they're making us free money man
and there we go right as we recheck the
price on the website the arm doe chest
plates instantly selling at what it
promised like I literally can't make
this up I just bought it and just sold
it 21.9 look at 60k made in just seconds
guys it's been two minutes I've flipped
like five armadyl crossbows gonna
literally put it for just under twenty
one point nine mil here
yeah no luck with the saradomin godsword
I'm just gonna abort that spectral
speared shields are traded white often
just gonna look into it right here click
here to go to the graphs and yeah it
just updated about eight minutes ago
it's flipping for a nice profit gonna
put it in for forty seven six seventy
three and I think that's the last our
middle cross but we can flip
we've bought one two three four five six
seven we can flip one more putting the
tormented bracelets in for like 10k
lower last arm de crossbow just came
through let's sell it off the ranger
tunics caught my eye because I know this
is bought by a lot of peers out there
we're gonna put an offer in for four of
them and the spectral just sold very
nice we instantly got one of the tunics
back for cash which is really weird
because I think someone just dumped one
of them so I'm not gonna be too scared
about that but yeah spectra bought it
forty 7-6 7-3 forty seven seven to seven
I'm gonna put it in for forty seven
seven to five that's what I like to see
the spectral speared shield
sold finally the tormented bracelet I've
got another pair of the boots just gonna
spend a big chunk of my cash and buy
three more because these are selling
very fast I didn't actually just believe
how fast that's sold for profit there we
go last are middle chest play coming
through and yeah these these boots are
just insane guys flips by the second
this is what happens when you have your
hands on something like this when you're
flipping because it just makes your life
a heck of a lot easier we're gonna try
to pick out a juicy item like I don't
know man look at this margin on the
industrial rope top 334 K when I see
stuff like that I just want to go for it
yeah we're gonna put it in for ninety
seven point four mill 89 K alright we've
been flipping these so fast we can
actually only buy two more so I'm just
gonna finish with these hope the
ancestral rope top buys and then look
for a new item don't really know how I
missed the armor it'll change skirts
going for 43 K flips and it's being sold
and bought very quickly these just from
rope top just came through hold on guys
so we bought at it around this price and
now we can sell for ninety seven point
seven mil honestly if we can get it for
this I will be so happy now something I
think that will work really well is two
dragon Warhammer so what I'm gonna do is
support the chain skirt sixty four point
three five eight mill and finally got
that dragon Warhammer
I really hope a team decides to do corp
right as I sell this and then that'll be
like a 40k flip we have these just a
real top it's still not selling probably
just because no one's buying it alright
the dragon war hammer and the umberto
plate skirt came in at the same time
don't really think I can flip another
dragon Warhammer in a minute in half but
we'll try alright we just bought another
dragon Warhammer and we're about to hit
the hour mark there it is guys as you
can see we just hit the 1 hour mark cut
the 21 milliseconds there as well I'm
just going to put the dragon Warhammer
back in and I'm just gonna wait for
these three items to sell and then once
they have we're gonna collect and see
how much we've made in one hour flipping
there it is of course three minutes
after the hour ends I get these
two items but there it is the ancestral
robe top flip as you can see we bought
it for nine seven four eight nine
it sold for almost a 200k profit just
off that one item and we're gonna
collect the arboreal chained skirt and
oh we broke the one mil mark guys which
was now what you guys have all been
waiting for how much did we make it not
one hour 1 millon 49 K it's before you
guys roast me that's me flippin I don't
know if game knowledge on like the best
items we still maybe one milk thank you
again to these staff but for real you
gotta give them props now some other
cool things I want to show you is the
high volumes tab it shows you high
volume items that have some decent
margins where you can make a lot of
money off them which is really cool and
it has a bunch of information about that
right here as you can see it is under
flip finder another thing is decant
potions guys it tells you how much
profit you can make off to canting
potions which is like another form of
flipping it's under the money making tab
you have the high alkaviva style prices
the best herb-lore profit the best item
sets profit like it just like the list
just goes on and on they put so much
time into developing this website and I
really respect that that's why I'm
showcasing it and that's why I am
promoting it and it does support the
YouTube channel it also shows you all
the users active in the last hour and
guys last thing I want to touch up on
here as you can see they're doing a bond
giveaway they're giving away eight bonds
for Premium Members Only
if this website does interest you in any
way guys after what you've seen today
make sure you go check it out where I'll
put the referral link in the description
if you guys wish to sign up using that
link to support me go ahead I think I'm
gonna give to people 500k okay no one
wants to respond
we found Ashley Queen you want to trade
bloom ass going on with the adamant G
nobody responds man all right we got
some guy head-banging in the myth with
the power and me 500k and and buy some
adamant I don't know do you do what you
want to ask yourself out man there may
be Ashley Queen will respond
how hard can it be just right-click my
character very simple two-step process
Dale what does that mean dude what what
does that mean okay here we go
take my money okay yes give me your
earth room good deal
enjoy was that so hard I just walk away
just just just just walk away
anyways now that we're done that we've
come to the conclusion of the video if
you guys made it this far your true
baller be sure to sub be sure to enter
the bond giveaway guys leave a comment
with your rsn remember eight bonds
you're giving away eight bonds and I'll
be giving them away when we hit 5,000
subscribers can't believe we're hitting
this number so quickly again I'll remind
you if you want to check out GE tracker
use the link in the description and if
you appreciate their work and enjoy the
site and sign up for premium if you like
the trial
go for it knock yourselves out big
thanks to them again for giving me the
premium and testing it out for you guys
until next time